hello I'm dan crowd welcome to our
GameSpot video about me licking things
the internet is just stoked to like
switch games
apparently they taste really bad so I
decided to look an n64 card of Majora's
Mask and also my switch cart of Zelda
breath of the wild taste fine so I like
to label okay how much of it all of it
okay holy [ __ ] it's really bad they're
not lying oh oh it's spicy
no it's seriously bad this isn't
[ __ ] this isn't like it into that
thing where you think they're lying this
is legitimately terrible but don't take
my word for it he's David Chang CNN
video producer looking the same
cartridge I just leaked
please enjoy does give yourself taste as
bad as Nintendo please like the label oh
my god oh boy good freefall I just
looked battery-like I think I'm about to
die either that will get like some
sweets it's spicy I'll give you that
it's not that bad
[Music]
maybe if he's all the tasty yeah it's
Asian palate maybe like the wild taste
it just dance
okay Zola's definitely stronger she's
going she's going with breath of the
wild you were your just dance mega
family okay it's it doesn't go away it's
peppery right it's spicy thank you
[Music]